Olha só o que Harvard acabou de
descobrir. Pois é, publicaram na Nature
essa semana que o lítio, aquele mineral
que temos naturalmente quantidades
pequeninas no cérebro, pode ser a chave
que estava faltando para entender o
Alzheimer. Veja bem, os pesquisadores
descobriram que quando o lítio começa a
cair no cérebro, isso pode ser um dos
primeiros sinais da doença antes mesmo
os sintomas aparecerem. E o que acontece
é fascinante. O lítio fica sequestrado,
preso naquelas placas de betamilóide,
que são a marca registrada do Alzheimer.
É como se o mineral fosse um bombeiro
tentando apagar o incêndio, mas fica
preso nos escombros. Sem ele circulando,
o cérebro perde proteção. Nos ratinhos
testados, quando deram um tipo especial
de lítio orotato que não gruda nas
placas, a memória melhorou com doses bem
pequenininhas, sem efeitos tóxicos.
Agora, calma aí. Não é para sair tomando
lítio por conta própria, viu? Estamos
falando de pesquisa em fase inicial. Mas
isso reforça algo que sempre falo,
cuidar do cérebro com sono de qualidade,
alimentação antiflamatória, exercício
físico, faz toda a diferença.